scored that against the Lakers a couple
of years ago he sees an opening and boy
did he step on the gas gets Wiggins out
of position gets the foul and before you
don't get he likes to slash little
jumper at the base three ball is knocked
down by a Kogi God he putting it on
display here in quarter number one nice
job of using his left hand any time you
run the floor e LeBron will find you and
Auntie Devi just completely shadowed
that basket
[Applause]
akun LeBron finds him and then they
opened the gate for LeBron he says okay
I don't have to pass every time exactly
the same from the field six out of nine
[Applause]
by Anthony Davis boy won't work they're
doing in socks he's got 64 now on the
year rebound McGee quickly to look long
Longley trying to fight against a star
Oriol leading the way as he has got the
Lakers up by fool Anthony towns is
assigned of abroad this time down the
war
LBJ inside has a big on the edges
waltzing around he said not let me set
you up for this triple here and he steps
back and drains the ball long ball to
create gypsy by Caruso
turn it over make this habit quick cook
he's gonna go all the way lay it up an
egg before Union trip try to attack
these look good defense by please they
deny at the red nail Alex to the story
LeBron quarterbacking bounces now to
Koosman from good shooting game up in
Oregon with six to shoot
LeBron is deep he'll let it go and out
it goes
played Gus your honor is well with two
minutes into the second quarter lead by
seven they have kept the trail yes sir
tack Corky engine flushed him Wow
they're almost vintage look how high he
was on that but no they make all three
of those free throws who's there lead is
the Braun and ad with the communications
just reading what each other is doing
Ron first and assists 10 point 7 per
came would be a career-high for
fire tests on Danny Green for three
for Andrew Wiggins Caruso with some
speed Davis coming down the middle right
to the word again the Lakers go over
seven feet hit the first half for the
second game in a row before 1881 the
travail here back into the game again
LeBron with four fouls
starting the half that's afraid for
right there he knocks it down 76 68
please watch it's one of the pre throws
ad in the lane softly to that touch soft
touch
spinning underneath and follow adds the
defense by karl-anthony towns and
company that's a photo ops control right
to LeBron right to LeBron and he says a
I'm taking this you see the shot clock
up there were 22 on it when it went
through the net they only averaged nine
points a game in transition they got 20
already JCP to finish and it was that
defeat
four minutes into the quarter bounce
that ad in he goes left hand off the
windows got 32 points ladies who plays
you and this University number one thing
to the trap
here comes Jeff a boy a disguise 16 is
the all-time bug and the Lakers will get
it if you got it Danny Green again the
broad in the attacking zone kcpy books
outside
[Music]
last few games where his defense is
really good on the play and he's not
afraid to miss a couple of job you know
an ultimate slow start to the year for
him help out it they rebound and when
especially when they run the floor good
block by Anthony gave us and then
running the floor now he's got a little
sheet really four with three that's
tough shot over Jordan go to number
three this guy is just a baby pass out
to turnover for the easy deuce for
Caruso
now I brought back again on Teague
caldwell-pope surrounded all the farmer
to this passing finding guru so as their
winter season high for AC look at the
ball movement one two three four
if you move the ball I looked at their
timber wolves chasing and just like that
it's an 11-point game yeah challenges
one for six of - out Caruso go but the
cleanup by Davis
beat the Seahawks in keeping their
playoff hopes alive down at the Kali
Lakers with boots when starting this
fourth quarter makers are a +5
rebounding tonight bran is being
defended by Napier and FC from total
mismatch he lost 1:16 to 108 throwing an
eight-point lead and eight minutes to
play
LeBron the double and it goes right to
quite pretty alley you Lakers have
knocked down 11 threes Green has made
four of them stolen by ad took caruso he
gets tripped up Lando at Miami the first
two on Wednesday and Friday
play around David Guetta's new CEO look
out behind LeBron sizing up the defector
covington Leblanc
yes sir right in his grill
LeBron says yeah take this bottoms it
out what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content